definitivamente es de mucho respeto de
solemnidad pero a este punto de la fila
la gente está feliz ya se siente cada
vez más cerca que van a lograr despedir
de manera personalmente a la reina
isabel segunda por quien sienten
admiración cariño y mucho respeto las
personas que están aquí que ustedes
pueden ver a mis espaldas han estado
haciendo fila por tres horas la buena
noticia es que si hay miles y miles de
personas pero la fila está avanzando
rápidamente lo que permitirá que
muchísimo más personas puedan unirse a
la fila se ha advertido que ésta ya es
de 5 kilómetros y puede llegar hasta los
16 kilómetros en los próximos días
porque como recordaba la reina estará en
cámara ardiente hasta el próximo lunes
19 de septiembre hasta las 6 y 30 de la
mañana apenas unas horas antes de ser
llevada a la abadía de westminster se ha
advertido entonces que el tiempo de
espera es largo y por ello el gobierno
ha habilitado un canal en youtube donde
la gente que espera unirse a la fila
puede y revisar exactamente en qué punto
del lado sur del río támesis debe unirse
y también les dice en el tiempo
aproximado de espera la reina isabel
como lo mencionas reposa en cámara
ardiente en este edificio del palacio de
westminster que tiene cerca de 900 años
de historia y está siendo monitoreado
las 24 horas por soldados con vestidos
rojos y dorados que la custodian las 24
horas y que están al servicio de la
reina isabel